allez on y va c'est l'indiquent de la
rédac cessa xalbat c'est parti lundi les
chez moi aussi je peux être beau mathieu
certains costumes la barre mythique
[Rires]
cabaret santos et jean pierre foucault
pas miss france bon ça c'est une entrée
comme ça je sais pas quand s'arrête à
rien on va voir peut-être après on se
retrouve dans un instant dans the boys
c'est pas mal on préfère que d'autres le
faire jean luc reichmann qui ont du cash
mais jean luc reichmann
est-ce qu'on a une petite musique des 12
coups de midi à sanaa les deux coups
raconter une anecdote a les yeux comme
si vous alors
alors donc j'ai été fort et ma femme est
l'avenir va chercher des pâtes et là je
vais dans la cuisine qui lui ramène
j'avais mal entendu je ramène des pâtes
j'en ai les pattes du sieur possible oui
bonjour vous êtes gaëtan vous avez vous
et on nous a raconté un petit truc
aujourd'hui whip alors ajouté
tranquillement en fait en train de jouer
au foot et là y'a un mec qui me les
fasse passer passe passe est en fait
j'ai pas entendu j'ai entendu tu as et
j'étais venu chercher une tasse de café
ou 10000 euros
bravo c'est sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'indic de la rédac i will indique imite
mais il a aussi des dossiers sur les
chroniqueurs vous savez je sais tout je
vois tout je dénonce tout et ce soir
j'ai pour la dernière j'ai évidemment
récolter la crème de la crème des
dossiers vous allez tous manger ce soir
je peux vous de bien vivre la nature des
âmes ont juré le savez ces dernières
semaines il ya un magnéto qu'on aime
bien c'est un amour de patron bien sûr
parce que pour cette dernière
évidemment l'équipe ont peut-être vous
manqué abbas à cesser de oui on a
beaucoup qui vont me manquer mais est ce
que vous avez manqué aux équipes
regardent cska est ce que ce dont je
suis en train de me rendre compte
la la comme ça aujourd'hui en 2020 après
ce qu'on vient d'y chanter comme que
vous ne connaissez pas et ça me fait
extrêmement mal
la durée des pubs elle est ou non dans
mon cul campagne sauvez clip back massa
magasin mais moi je n'ai pas besoin de
faire tout chez nous j'ai tout le monde
alors moi j'ai ensemble acquis à
personne alors toiture son psy aux gars
de vidéo gag que je reviens à clichy par
exemple je les vire pas besoin que tu me
le disent aller où valérie aller où
valérie valérie du public sur la
nouvelle révélée vous avez été nous
voilà je vous dit de plus en plus
l'année prochaine est ce que j'ai
vraiment besoin de chroniqueurs je fais
des scores énorme avec les boîtiers pas
de chroniqueuse au bon endroit supposons
que vous comme un gros oedème tu vas
géant gros oedème dans mon slip
connaissent dis pas que c'est une super
bonne me dis juste que c'est une idée de
mombasa
[Musique]
vous allez me manquer sur elle les gens
ont compris que c'était du marais
c'était mon kiff maintenant les pubs
sont très longues donc moi qui c'est
d'aller d emmerder franchement c'est mon
king tut sainty j'ai mis les paillettes
pour la dernière ouais je sais que mes
films et des paillettes aime les
rillettes exactement brown doit venir
vous voir cet été
oui bien sûr berthiaume abonnés si je
réussis ont fait ce que vous pouvez pas
accoster cagnotte de 35 mètres fois un
annexe pour venir vous une vanne qui
marchent pas une fois il veut la fin en
soi
bah oui mais je n'ai je suis nue et
s'est laissé entendre qu'il a de
l'argent c'est vraiment nul et cherry
qui a signé son contrat pour l'année
prochaine par ces personnes
en parlant d'oseille en parlant de
contrats comment vous êtes en ce moment
vous n'êtes pas un peu ric-rac tous
j'ai un passé assez quelqu'un en
particulier de leurs monnaies en or ou
non tommy non parce qu'il semblerait
qu'en ce moment l'argent coule pas à
flots en production vous allez voir je
peux traiter de losail le met en péril
toute rallonge fous toi
non c'est parti c'est pourquoi il
rappelé c'est que du kidjo adam
j'ai eu le virement
[Rires]
je dis quelque chose je pense que je
prends un pb de vent je suis flatté sur
le plateau de l'émission que ses
chroniqueurs vous vous êtes mariés parce
que vous êtes payé pas moi il n'ya plus
de pub qui les missions des six mois
maintenant
ah bon bah écoute il faut bien que on
paye les chroniqueurs moi tu sais que
moi là là c'est que du kif et apprendre
ici je fais gracieuse - je rigole pas ah
ouais il n'ose même pas dire que tout va
donc au nom mais les gars on a dû faire
des efforts c'est vrai merci à vous
d'ailleurs merci aux normales normal
voilà non je le dis la vérité c'est vrai
que les coûts de production ont
énormément baissé mais voilà lors de ces
dernières semaines après bien sûr ce
qu'on est avec moi qu'on a vécu et vous
avez tous fait des efforts nécessaires
merci à vous merci merci nous maintient
dans ses yeux
moi je suis normalement je suis venu un
rer mais ça me fait plaisir et puis oui
non raymond sans rigoler question
pensent pas c'est formidable c'est bien
non mais t'as pas dû pour moi je suis
content mais c'est dit on c'est légitime
qu'on fasse nous des efforts et va bien
sûr ces deux quintés dit je suis content
le crois moi je suis content on avait
des bons salaires vous avez tous des
casseurs alors c'est pas grave si on a
baissé pour saisir et qu'on détruit un
mois deux mois c'est pas très grave
allez c'est parti lundi tu voudrais
poser une question à matthieu delormeau
matthieu delormeau quelle est la
personne vous préférez dans ce studio
cyril et envie de goûter aux jo 1 dans
tout le studio jean mi le tueur un bas à
valérie j'ai pas j'aime tout le monde
quand as tu sais quand tu es un grand
coeur un peu de place pour les autres
alexandre a donc quitté alexandre si
c'est comme mon petit frère
comment ni sur l'île en small un ouais
j'en midi celui-ci maintient médecin
préféré botté qui hélas soraya regarder
sans rien c'est ma chérie sera ya ces
kits ont préféré toi ce qu'on peut
donner un micro à soria c'est possible
un micro main merci alors là c'est la
panique à bord alors oui ça n'y a pas de
lumière
pasqua alors vous êtes âgés sont si
maintenant elle est celle qui va c'est
qui votre préféré tout le monde sauf
mathieu lascaud est en vue j'ai jamais
dit que des belles choses sur lui ça lui
est arrivé il m'a cartonné alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez pourtant on a
des images et je pense que c'est une
grande histoire d'amour qui naît entre
eux avant il ya mathieu sauvera ya deux
mois de la matière macho et où j'ai viré
tout le monde parce que j'ai
l'impression que je peux tout faire
moi-même étant faut descendre qu'on
avait pu pendant l'émission
ça paraît la base oui enfin un peu de
bon sens n'at-il pas les gens à
l'antenne kaunas ouais ouais ouais bien
le dire ici si tu oses ma famille
lavalas ça reprend donc là ça reprend
misogyne et lâche
soraya ma chérie items bien entrer c'est
bien quand même hein tu me connais c'est
mignon 10h aux gens qu'on aime a bien
qui comment on bosse beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de tension et les nations et
bien décompresser comme on bosse
beaucoup
lundi que s'est intéressée à bernard
montiel
on l'a vraiment y aller ce que vous avez
eu des problèmes avec l'autorité étant
plus jeune oui c'est vrai oui oui oui
eh bien on l'a remarqué vous savez lundi
qu'ils avaient déjà repéré un bernard
nicod book
eh bien figurez-vous que bernard a
récidivé il a failli à votre autorité
cyril a beau et j'ai les preuves
comment est ce possible regardez
beaucoup disent même talent éclate aussi
dans les coulisses on sait pas on sait
pas d'instinct en plateau j'adore rire
est un métissage leur passé quoi là
c'est plus dur pour ça c'est l'échec
[Musique]
à
berne à outines sans révéler les bars
montiel c'est pas possible
quoi c'est un coup c'est devenu un
influenceur avec les wilayas marius à la
meuf là allez on y va à l'an prochain
magnéto cyril je vais pas m'attarder
dessus parce que c'est un acronyme qui
s'appelle ctc est ce que quelqu'un sait
ce que ça veut dire c'était à moi je
sais mais fournier là où un vieux on a
on a la réponse
je peux vous dire que c'est pas joli
joli non mais tu es fou quoi je suis
capable enfin si on va le mettre mais
c'est pas tout à la tâche nice et rennes
s'étaient pas ce qu'on appelle une ctc
sais quoi parce qu'on n'a pas le ctc une
chatte très chaudes c'était céline
concessionnaire a plein d'argent
c'était chose que je serai pas même
salle est allé en enchaînant dauchy non
il ya ya ya ya quelqu'un qui vais bien
mathieu ah oui à quand même oui parce
qu'il n'ya pas que sans rien avec qui il
ya une histoire d'amour il ya le manque
d'une les membres du public aussi qui
vous aiment à rien il ya une jeune fille
du public on a adoré
et oui je crois que tu es valérie dagand
agitation préféré tout annuler et
valérie elle nous a dit que son
connecteur préféré c'était mathieu
delormeau
ça peut paraître étonnant et elle a même
dit à l'antenne les deux meilleures
interventions ce sont les personnes son
époux gérard est la grande question mode
propose à la place de l'ormeau
c'était de la chan dans deux mois en
fait
[Applaudissements]
bravo pagola n'aime pas non plus à
l'audience ça va pas tepa est terrible
leur lien direct au mamac 6,7 me v'là
magali chez mon avenir c'est une
téléspectatrice c'est des gros bisous
magani tes fans
magali est génial c'est magali en fait
un mba matthew oui et elle vous adore un
cd regarde tous les gens qui sont assis
sur le canapé général on vous adore
n'at il est toujours avec bizarrement je
sais c'était mon préféré
ouais mais en vrai c'est un connard
c'est ça et bien moi même mais en fait
les gens vous et vous vraiment nous ont
vraiment bien cerner merci c'est tout
pas aujourd'hui oui c'est tout tandis
que terminer j'ai pas de supporter
longtemps pourquoi cyril un monde où
paul ou alors j'ai c'est que sacha sera
avec nous l'année prochaine une fois par
semaine par mois par mois oui la
nouvelle vague
c'est un lieu où cet été le capitaine
planter ou cet été je vais travailler la
chronique pour l'année prochaine
peut-être à la webapp commence dès
maintenant
[Rires]